yesterday during the bitcoin conference
was a massive announcement from jack
muller's and strike first it's important
to understand that in the payment
industry there hasn't been true
innovation in almost 60 years jack in
his presentation walked through step by
step how these payment networks actually
process transactions and why there
hasn't been any sort of true innovation
and then he made two major announcements
the first is that strike jack's company
is going ahead and integrating with
shopify this means that any shopify
merchant in the entire world now has
bitcoin and lightning network support
available to them as any person who
wants to purchase an item through a
shopify store i can go on and i can pay
in dollars i can pay in bitcoin or any
other currency in the world that payment
will be processed by the lightning
network there will be zero fees attached
to it there's cash finality and instant
settlement the merchant receives 100 of
the money that i pay
and also they get to choose the currency
in which they receive that funds in so
first and foremost
uh strikes officially partnered with
shopify
[Applause]
so it's live
go check it out
i i dream i look up to this brand warren
lotus it's one of the best
streetwear fashion brands in the world
like all my favorite athletes and my
favorite rappers they all wear it super
popular
i call them i'm like yo guys
there's a cheaper faster
more innovative more inclusive way to
accept payments i'm not pulling your
chain bro i swear to god you use shopify
right he goes yeah i use shopify
i i mean and i know that
you used the wazzah rails from 1949
but let me plug you into this
let me plug you into this ultimately the
shopify integration is going to start
off slowly but it's going to ramp up and
every shopify merchant in the world is
going to realize
using strike as the payment processor
via the lightning network is superior to
using any other payment network that is
available then jack mullers followed
that up and he had a second announcement
not only have they partnered with
shopify they also have partnered with
blackhawk and ncr now many of you have
never heard of blackhawk or ncr and
that's okay
but they are two of the largest payment
processors in the world they cover about
85 percent of all u.s retail merchants
companies like mcdonald's walmart and
many others and because strike now is
integrating with blackhawk and ncr that
means you'll be able to walk in anywhere
from mcdonald's walmart cvs or the
hundreds and hundreds of other retailers
and you'll again be able to pay in
dollars euros bitcoin or any currency
that you choose that payment will then
be processed via the lightning network
and the merchant will receive 100 of the
funds there will be cash finality
instant settlement and they will get to
choose which currency they receive
eighty percent of payments are still
done in person
no matter how innovative cash app is
no matter how awesome venmo is no matter
how cool robinhood is
they all integrate the lightning network
it doesn't matter
because when i walk into a grocery store
they don't understand it they only
understand the diners club caviar party
so that's why strikes also partnered
with blackhawk blackhawk is
one of the largest payment providers in
the world for alternative payments
they have 400 000
storefronts
and 37 000
partners
that they're the ones that are behind
[ __ ] like this have you ever checked
yourself out at a cvs
you ever used one of these
and then my hay maker
we've also partnered with the largest
point of sale provider in the entire
planet
ncr
yeah
because we just got to give merchants
the new superior alternative payment
network and so
this year have you guys ever shopped at
any of these
any of these
yeah
this is true innovation being brought to
the payment sector jack mullers just
took the lighting network and he
integrated with shopify and with about
85 percent of u.s retail merchants
ultimately there will be millions and
millions and millions of americans and
even more globally they will come
together they will start to use the
lighting network in a material way and
now that we're able to connect the
bitcoin community and the bitcoin rails
to everyday businesses and people who
are offline that tends to mean that this
is not only good for bitcoin it's not
like good for strike but it's also good
for the merchants that's the key pieces
because now they're incentivized to
actually start to adopt bitcoin the
payment network the superior payment
network
visa and mastercard they're in trouble
because now we have an instant
settlement no fee cash finality system
it doesn't require the approval or the
participation of a third party don't bet
against bitcoin don't bet against jack
mullers don't bet it gets strike
and ultimately don't bet against
progress hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time